[Music]
tomorrow is the 10th anniversary of the
night that trayvon martin was killed you
remember this story the 17 year old
teenager was gunned down on his way home
by neighborhood watch volunteer george
zimmerman who was found not guilty of
second-degree murder
the cbs reports one hour special trayvon
martin ten years later is what we're
calling it explores a legacy in the
impact of his death it features
interviews with his mother sabrina
fulton and other mothers of the movement
whose children have been killed by
police or gun violence and those on the
front line of the social justice
movement we visited the annual peace
walk held in trayvon's honor and this
year it happened to fall on what would
have been his 27th birthday
[Music]
what did you think when you saw the
crowd today
i think i was good when i woke up this
morning i prayed i
meditated and so i was feeling really
really
like excited and really ready and really
excited but then when i drove in the
gate and i saw so many people and i'm
just
it just made me tear up
[Music]
it made me tear up and it made me
realize
the impact of trayvon martin
ten years ago sabrina fulton became the
mother of a movement
we got to see past
what's in front of us
we can't give up her son trayvon martin
was just 17 years old when he was gunned
down while walking back to his father's
house from the convenience store he was
shot by george zimmerman a neighborhood
watch volunteer who was 28. the pain is
still fresh
the hurt is still fresh the
disappointment and sadness is still
fresh so it seems like it happened
recently
and i have to remind myself that it's
been 10 years this year an annual peace
walk and peace talk held in trayvon
martin's hometown miami florida fell on
what would have been his 27th birthday i
have to say every time i look at that
it's now an iconic photo of him ms hoody
i see your face
i see you when i look at him what do you
see when you look at him
i see at times pain
i see
i still see trey
i still see
my baby boy
but there is something to smile about
you know i'm grateful that i did have
him for 17 years
but
the pain and hurt and bitterness of him
not still being here
is something that i carry with me every
day
i've heard you say that you turned your
pain into purpose what do you mean when
this first happened the tragedy of my
son i can absolutely say that
i never thought i would be happy again i
never thought i would smile again and i
asked god for strength because that's
what i heard other people saying about
me
how strong i was it didn't happen
overnight but he made me strong it
happened sabrina fulton realized there
was power in sisterhood she created the
circle of mothers for women who have
lost children or family members to
senseless gun violence
when sabrina did the circle of mothers
i remember i became so broken but i left
so empowered it's been a sisterhood that
we have formed together to encourage
each other to support each other to cry
with each other they're still shooting
us they're still killing us but we are
still visible we are still telling them
that we're not quitting this is our life
now
boy you can watch trayvon martin 10
years later on the cbs news streaming
network and the smithsonian channel
that's tomorrow at eight o'clock eastern
and you can also watch it on monday on
bet at eight o'clock eastern also those
channels are part of our parent company
paramount
see all those mothers standing together
really talks about the scope of what's
going on in this country you know i
wonder what they told you about how for
so long these types of cases would end
with acquittals and then now we have
recent convictions like in the case of
ahmad arbury and george floyd what do
they say about that so much has changed
but so much has also stayed the same i
know and i asked that very question
adriana because they said
listen we are very happy about what
happened in those two cases but sabrina
called it bittersweet she said you take
two steps forward and then you take two
steps back and what it took to get to
those acquittals and there's still as
she said a lot of injustice that happens
that people are not being held
accountable same with tamika tamika who
is brianna taylor's mother she is
certainly one of those people who
doesn't feel that she has gotten justice
in her daughter's death so that while
they welcome those verdicts of course
they still know that there's still so
much work to be done and people are
still not being held accountable in the
way that they would like to see
yeah so much uh happened in these 10
years and i i hope the documentary gets
into the comments from president obama
you'll recall uh back in 2012 lebron
james put a hoodie on in solidarity with
with trayvon martin that was a big part
of the story
we get into all of that we have an
interview with eric holder as you know
was the attorney general at the time but
i keep thinking guys about sabrina
fulton she never asked for this and now
she's a public speaker something that
she she grabs but it's certainly not
where she wants to be
we'll be right back